Mm,
so why should someone who's in the
business of getting someone's attention,
why should somebody who runs a business
that's all about getting attention?
Why should they switch to being in the
business of helping people?
Well,
for one,
it's going to be hard to do that until
consumers actually demand that that's
what they want.
We all need to recognize this as
citizens of humanity.
It just being human,
that this world that's constantly
fighting to grab our attention doesn't
serve any of us.
It's,
it's polluting our inner and our social
lives.
And once we recognize that that's the.
We don't want that as consumers that
will enable businesses to follow
consumer demand and say we want to
provide something whose goals are
entirely in alignment with your goals,
where we measure our success in terms of
the net positive benefits that we
delivered in people's lives and we
charged more like a subscription model
or a payment model rather than
advertising where we have an infinite
appetite in stealing as much of your
attention as possible.
So you know,
when we check our phones 150 times a
day,
which is the average,
are those 150 conscious moments where
we're sitting here and then we think and
then we choose,
now I'm going to check my phone or does
it just happen to us?
And I think one thing that that we don't
talk about with the attention economy,
what's different about the attention
economy versus a,
a normal marketing product,
goods economy is that in the regular
economy people make a conscious choice
theoretically about the products that
they choose to buy or the places I
choose to go to,
I think get into a car and go there.
In the attention economy,
I don't choose where my intention goes.
I choose kind of in the moments in
between,
but a lot of my intention can be
steered.
This is what magicians do.
I mean they,
they do a trick by steering your
attention by focusing your attention
over here.
And so what's different about the
attention economy is we have less choice
about where our attention goes.
It can be steered and manipulated much
more easily than the conscious choice
buying economy when I'm choosing to buy
a good.
So.
So yeah.
So why are we checking our phones 150
times a day?
Why is this so compelling?
Well,
it's because at any given moment in life
when,
when I'm left with the uncomfort of
being with myself where reality gets
just a little bit boring for just a
moment.
If you have just a break,
you,
you walk into a cafe and there's a line
before you order.
What do we do?
Why do we pull out our phone in that
moment in a world where this has
increasingly,
you know,
gives you access to anything that you
want at any given moment or the ability
to get back to those 10 emails or the
ability to watch that video you've been
meaning to watch.
Why would you not turn to your phone in
that free moment?
So we have to reckon with a world in
which next door to my current to moment
experience of reality.
There's this immediately sweeter,
better choice.
And if that's true for every human being
walking around,
we just put a better choice on life's
menu in your pocket that at any moment
you can switch to suddenly the world is
gonna look a lot like it does today
where everyone is down on their phones.
Right?
And it's the point isn't that suddenly
we're just distracted or something like
that,
that we have to really get intimate
with.
Why is this happening?
And the reason it's happening is because
it's more compelling than simply being
with the discomfort of reality as it is,
which is going to force us to ask some
really deep questions with,
with ourselves of if we were to not live
that way,
if we were to live,
uh,
not looking at our phone in a free
moment in time,
would we be willing to deal with
sometimes being a little bit
uncomfortable or being a little bit
bored?
Um,
and when we make that choice,
we don't just make that alone because,
you know,
imagine that person who meditates in the
morning and suddenly says,
you know,
I really,
I'm not going to look at my phone today.
And so they,
they,
they land in that line in the cafe and
they don't look at their phone and
they're kind of looking around smiling,
but suddenly everyone around them is
still on their phone.
And what real realize realizes is that,
you know,
it's sort of like a weekend isn't just
for us,
it's about being in a weekend together.
If we don't look at our phone,
we don't just want to not look at our
phone by ourselves.
We'd want to actually be able to connect
together and more connecting with other
people.
It makes realities as sweet actually as
the things that our phone provides
because the whole point is like when,
when you're in connection with someone
else in your,
that actually is more compelling than
being with our phones.
But when you're just by yourself sorting
for what's going to be the most
stimulating or productive or
entertaining way for me to be right now,
oftentimes our phone will beat out other
choices that are appearing before us.
Um,
and it's only when we're with other
people that,
uh,
and we're,
we're in connection or conversation with
someone else that,
that actually is better than often.
You know,
these individual choices we can get on a
phone because we actually do desire
connection.
Wouldn't.